I met him a few months ago with one of
my best friends in New York and he was
just like a very nice guy and he's
almost my age so we kind of got along
together
that's Gisele Bundchen nearly 20 years
ago talking about Leonardo DiCaprio
right before they started dating here's
my friend
the supermodel I'm the actor famously
dated from 2000 to 2005 and now she's
opening up about her decision to walk
away from leo
quote no longer numbing myself with
smoking drinking and too much work I was
becoming more and more aware of things
that I'd chosen not to look at was I
alone in wanting to do some serious
soul-searching while he stayed the same
in the end
unfortunately the answer was yes yikes
38 year old gets candid inside Porter's
fifth anniversary issue where she also
dishes on now husband Tom Brady
revealing he is actually more into
fashion than she is quote Tom actually
loves clothes more than I do sometimes I
am like what is all this clothing he
just loves it Gisele and her a
quarterback husband have been married
for nearly 10 years now and share two
kids together he's always told eg he
will support them in whatever career
path they choose for themselves whatever
things they like to do you know I want
to be able to support them so I think it
whether it's sports or whether it's
music or whether it's you know something
with the arts or you know I wanted to
obviously you know you know you could
grade be respectful of people who knows
that they play sports if they do I think
it's great because I can really help
them out but if they don't you know that
son you know that's up today